hey good afternoon i'm assistant sheriff
brett zimmerman and i'm here to brief
you on additional details as we know
them today
about the officer-involved shooting that
occurred on monday
october 12 2020. this is ois
number 16 for 2020 and non-fatal number
eight
and at the same time last year we were
at ois number 14
and non-fatal number 10. the date time
and type of call
is was october 12 2020
at 308 a.m and it was an illegal gunfire
call
the location of the ois was at the 3500
block of villa
knowles drive north drive and it's
picture to my left
it was in the southeast area command
and the full address was uh las vegas
nevada 89120
on the villanova's drive address you can
see the scene to my left
our involved officers were officer
curtis paul he's 27 years of age
and he's been with the lvmpd since 2017.
in this incident officer paul was armed
with a glock 17 nine millimeter handgun
equipped with a tactical light the
investigation revealed he fired seven
rounds during the incident officer paul
is assigned to the community policing
division
at the southeast area command the
suspect is a shane lloyd
he's pictured to my left one l in his
name
he's a 43 year old white male adult
six foot one and weighs a hundred and
eighty pounds
his weapon was a ruger single six 22
magnum revolver and there were six
expended cartridges
in the cylinder and the photo is to my
left
our suspects charges who was in custody
shooting into an occupied structure
four counts attempt murder with use of a
deadly weapon
two counts assault with a deadly weapon
on a po
two counts assault with a deadly weapon
and prohibited person in possession of a
firearm
the details of the ois are as follows on
monday october 12
2020 at 308 am patrol officers responded
to the 3500 block
of villanol's north drive to investigate
a report of gunfire
patrol officers arrived and did not find
any evidence that a shooting had
occurred
during the investigation the officers
contacted a citizen
who had an unserved temporary protective
order
what we some what we call a tpo for
short
as officers were standing in front of
the patrol vehicle finishing up
paperwork
the suspect later identified as shane
lloyd
approached them from behind and fired
three rounds in their direction
officer paul turned around and returned
fire at lloyd
lloyd fled and as he was running away he
fired backwards towards the officers
as the officers ran towards the threat
and the gunfire
officer paul returned fire again and
then took cover
lloyd continued running and the officers
then lost sight of him
additional units arrived and established
a perimeter
however lloyd was not located at that
time
during the search officers located
lloyd's weapon
and clothing in a dumpster behind a
nearby business
lloyd was apprehended that day by a
south central area command patrol
officer
who worked closely with the area command
units at the southeast area command
exhausting all leads and looking to
ident looking to find
where lloyd was staying
at this time i will now show you the
body-worn camera footage
yeah so just um call that number
tomorrow and say hey you know
[Music]
unfortunately
um
[Music]
okay that concludes the briefing if
anybody has any questions
yes sir
what we did that morning is immediately
we start canvassing the area
exhausting leads we saturate
we were able to speak to some homeless
individuals in that area
who had known the suspect's description
and known he was a problem in the area
he also had a social media account and
through investigation we were able to
identify him
as that individual according to his
nickname
and some other factors but we were able
to do that pretty quickly
from the briefing i got it was uh not
registered locally
and it was it shows dating way back to
texas but it's not reported stolen
is this suspect related to the first
shooting that you received
that we do not know uh the suspect
actually confessed
to this incident but also uh he did not
uh associate himself with that first
shooting of the gunfire that we had
uh we don't really know that usually
after the fact when we interview them
the story changes but he he didn't uh
he didn't give any information as to why
he fired at us
judging from that area and judging from
one way in and one way out
and if you're familiar with that area
you can see in you can see everything in
that complex
from tropicana you know i would have to
say that
he was aware that police officers were
in that community at that time when he
was firing those rounds
with what's been going
yes you know our training and tactics
are second to none in the country we
teach our officers
and train our officers very well as you
can see from these body-worn
this body-worn camera video shots are
fired at them they immediately react
they return fire they take cover they're
able to chase but
yeah you know with what's going on
around the country we're on
you know we're out there to protect the
public you know there was also a citizen
out there that we were speaking with and
gun
and and and you know they they they get
gunfire towards them
so they run towards that gun gunfire
like the heroes that they
are and still do their jobs on a daily
basis but yeah you know we we train
every day and we feel we're ready for
situations like this you know you know
if it is proven that it was actual
ambush
not only does this video uh or
press conference go to the media and to
the public but we do an awareness report
immediately
when an incident like this occurs such
as monday morning when it occurred
they actually then see the exact press
briefing
that you see and then there's also a
discussion about it within our briefings
as to what occurred
within a week too there's a there's a
a training process which we call cert in
which we look at the tactics that are
utilized not only by
by our officers but that tactics are
utilized
against us by suspects on how we can
improve every day
on and how we can protect the public do
our job safely and keep everybody safe
within the community
okay thank you for your time